now welcome to this video playing genome
Ganim from the Slovenia actually yeah
the Slovenia my current favorite country
to spend the holidays in okay I know the
Slovenian flag by now it's just very
very very little here this is the symbol
okay
so we have a London system where black
of course got more than one good reply
and this is one of them still it's not
done leading to to black advantage or
something it's just an interesting
position to play ideas to play e5 this
Bishop on d5 is a funny piece but it has
got some sense and purpose yet
controlled squares and it's not so clear
that white really wants to play the move
C form I can take on f3 and then
establish some nice pressure on the long
diagonal I actually think that c4 is not
so great iam but my idea is 5 now and
grabbing the initiative in the center
it's not clear what what should should
do
yeah
if I'm facin yeah I'm not sure it is
really a threat but some at least
gaining some space yeah this is a
possible possible move attacking on v6
question is what now b5 not be success
it's embarrassing don't want to do that
I could simply take it it's not it's not
bad but probably just him to to cover b6
and maybe prepare b5
the bishop on d5 is still a funny piece
aha okay he's trying to make use of it
can I can play b5 now beehive but he
goes to D to e m and then d5 Hanks and
his threatening Eve form I don't want
that
hmm okay
but if it takes on see if I can take see
for him it's a it's still alright I
don't really see - this isn't the threat
here I'll take one see for maybe yeah
I can I can do some prep Museum I'm also
thinking about the move f5 it's
technically very very tricky but it
would nicely increase my control over
you form of course at the moment f5 s is
just nonsense because it takes on c5 my
bishop is saying and if I take it it's a
check on c4 so but it's it's it's maybe
I'm a way to to look a for is an
interesting gradually okay so we get
this this transformation I didn't I
didn't feel that I thought that here I
always should have this nice structure
the good center and a potential to play
b5 before in the long run he's got
Bishop b5 but this is rather passer just
blocking this okay so if I go what could
be aged now I'm intending b5
b5 before it would be very nice
uh-huh so he's but I have might be six
yeah this is good
pre retreats to f3 airplane I'd a for
this is excellent for black
hmm interesting
I didn't didn't think about that move at
all
you know I can I can do that not not
sure that this is the best but it's it's
not it's not bad yeah but he won't
manage a complete blockade on the
queenside
I get in b5 before
when Bishop f6 he always has 94 which is
annoying
before before it's the problem he cannot
if he would have the time to play a four
night C 4 B 3 block at all and it's nice
for him but I don't see how it prevents
b5 before yeah this is what we can try
so at 5 and then Bishop a 6 a.m. ok
probably first here just is that you
don't have g5
now before you know let's go
yeah it's not no plan to defend
threatening on c3 if he takes rook takes
this also a flying night h4 is the only
idea that I see yeah but it's not I can
take for us this is what I'm trying to
say now gain the tempo on this rook oh
no but I can just take it
white resigns now if he takes key one I
take g6 yeah I think around here this is
some quite a decent position for black
I've got a good structure and the
bishops especially this bishop this
bishop is just biting on on granite it
doesn't do much yeah after that I think
it's looking it's looking nicely the guy
have just this 7 weakness which I can
easily cover and he cannot really
prevent behind before yeah the computer
already gives me a decisive edge here
it's it's really hard to to defend this
gives this as the relatively best line
the problem is that just have a look at
this that all those pawns are weak I
mean I probably win at least two of them
before in d5 and this is actually enough
already
after that I've got the better minor
piece the extra pawn it's too much you
know I think what he needs to do is here
to play em to just just keep the
position and don't take on c5 which is
not a mistake but it doesn't really help
him
I think this isn't my eases up my play
here
even he can do all kinds of prep moves
rookie one or something and there's not
much not much happening I mean I had the
idea to play a rook a forge which I
think was interesting let's say he plays
anonymous I had the Zook a for India I'm
not quite sure if it is good attacking
here and the other compass completely
unimpressed and says this is good for
watch don't really believe that but
maybe complicated I thought that be
three a four would be helpful for me but
maybe it's not the case yeah an
interesting game I hope you liked it